[ __ ] i just remembered bang sorry sorry
to [ __ ] on banks again
um you can't i remember i was in
uh i was out in uh shibuya and i was out
till
like 2 a.m i was like all right well i
want to go home now
so i'm gonna get a taxi and i was like
great well i've got no money so i'll
just go and quickly go and get some
money from the atm
turns out that after working hours you
just can't withdraw money
so you know if uh [ __ ] me i was stranded
in the middle of nowhere yeah right i'll
get money
have to wait until what 8 a.m until the
banks open up for some reason
so the atms start [ __ ] wood
i've never i don't think i've ever had
to i don't think i've ever had to take
money out like
that i know sometimes i have a good
night you know i spent more than i
intended to i've got no more cash left
no bigger i'll get some from the atm
right no [ __ ] me [ __ ] me and even if it
is during
working hours i gotta pay anyway what am
i paying for it's an atm
there's no one there there's no one in
the machine giving me money is there is
just a small man sleeping in the machine
who's awake during these hours why is it
this much yeah like like
there are some atm like to to to explain
there are some atms in the uk
that do charge to take money out but
they are like
they're like the like no branded atms
yeah
at some sketchy like those are the ones
where like there's probably a man inside
yeah
yeah those are the ones where it's
[ __ ] 2 a.m or something you just need
some [ __ ] money out to go to the club
or something and you're like sure
i'll pay 5 pounds to take out my 20
pound entry fee to this club
whatever i'm drunk enough to do it no no
imagine now
imagine that but for every transaction
you do and that's that's taking out
money here in japan yeah you have to
take out a lot of money
yeah they charge like five bucks i think
each time or something yeah they charge
like just like
five bucks everybody to access unless
you go to that
bank's branded atm but even then
sometimes they charge you
yeah because yeah because you have a
limit as to how many times you can take
money out per month but that depends
if if you for some reason you're rich
[ __ ]
and you you have x amount of money in
your bank it's free they're like no no
it's on us
you have a lot of money with us we ain't
going to charge you punishment
are you taxing the [ __ ] poor people
what the [ __ ]
that's just like what's wrong it's like
everything in this system is designed to
make you hate them
damn it capitalism like like i i
when i was when i when i wanted to get
the taxi home i was like i'm so
goddamn lucky that i ca i have a foreign
card that i could carry on me at
emergency yes because i'm like you never
know
yeah my my foreign my british card is
just like my get away get out of jail
free card yeah so so
it's like 100 more reliable than using
the card
in the country it was made from like how
does that work my british bank
card works every single atm at any time
of the day
whenever and they bet they don't charge
me they just charge me the exchange rate
cost which
i accept you know because i'm changing
the money whatever they've got to do
but you know i i don't i genuinely don't
know how i would have got home that
night
if i if i didn't have my british card
what did you happen easy will do in this
they'll just go to the [ __ ]
manga cafes don't they well no because
that you'd have to pay for the modern
cafe and if you don't have cash you
can't even pay for it
they literally sleep outside of the
simulator for like six years
i mean you've probably seen it before
they literally sleep outside like
stations should be a meltdown [ __ ]
yes or should be a meltdown or something
else but like sometimes i've seen you
know walking past the station or
whatever
there's like couples and like you know
businessmen just sleeping outside of the
station waking waiting for it to wake up
yeah like it's ridiculous absolutely
insanity
like like talking about this now i'm
like i'm i'm i'm really starting to
sweat this year right because
um because of the world situation
haven't been able to travel back to the
uk
yeah and i look at the expiry date on my
card and it's like
it's like creeping up right because it
was it was like because before i moved
up death note because it sends you an
automatic one though at least my bank
does
yeah it sends me to my uk address which
no one is living in right now
because my parents are in [ __ ]
thailand i'm here in japan um so my my
i'm not gonna say what the exact day but
my exact address
it is it is in 2021 my expiry date for
my
british card and i'm just like
i'm i'm starting to swear because i'm
just like [ __ ] man if if i can't travel
back to the uk to get my new cards then
i'm kind of just like resting on my
japanese card to work my hands
20 23 we get gucci
yeah i mean that was a that was a nice
little rant
banks of hell here sorry most people
have absolutely
no care in the world about japanese
banks but now you know a lot more well
there's probably a lot
you know there's a lot of audiences of
trash taste who are like one day i want
to live in japan and live that weeb
dream just be prepared well
i i think we've done a good job at least
you know
bigging up the the stuff that is worth
you know giving honesty honestly
and we're brutally honest about the ship
parts honestly like all things
considered japan is
like i don't know if it's the best but
it's definitely like
either comparing the uk to japan it's
been a [ __ ] amazing place to live and
i don't know if i'll put it as the best
but it's definitely plus it's definitely
our way the minus
i think i think i i enjoy living here
yeah i'm right okay so
i mean i definitely have enjoyed my
previous year and a half more than i
have in the uk
um we'll see how i am five years down
the line you know yeah but right now i
can i'm definitely
i'm approaching my fifth year yeah i'm
definitely gonna be here for at least
two three more years i think yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah definitely
definitely because i [ __ ] love it
here it's so much fun it's an amazing
country so expect trash taste for at
least another
just just just don't just don't
tell me i have to move house or [ __ ]
change my internet
or change my phone because i am i'm
gonna get
just just tell me ahead of time when
that happens because i'll just [ __ ]
get out of there before i'm like
drinking like this rant
is me like mentally preparing for like
the the month
in like the month and this year that i'm
gonna have to dedicate to moving
yeah i mean paying taxes was way more
like much much more enjoyable than
doing any of the forms i had to do in
japan